Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism
living this yoga.
This episode is brought to you
by we work. I love, we work.
I haven't had an office in many,
many, many, many, many years.
Since 2000 or so when I had my last
real job I suppose and quotation marks,
but when I moved from San Francisco
to Austin, not long guy decided,
you know what?
I'm tired of working at home.
I'm tired or we're going to coffee shops.
So one of the very first things I
did was to get a space at we work.
I could not be happier with
this change in my life.
We work is a global network of workspaces
where companies and people grow
together. The idea is really simple.
You focus on your business and we work,
takes care of all of the rest,
including front desk service, utilities,
refreshments,
and more.
I also often have things shipped from
Amazon and elsewhere to my office that we
work here in Austin.
I've been completely blown away
by the members only events,
special offers,
and perhaps the best cold brew
coffee on tap that I've ever had.
It's been amazing.
It's been a real,
real change in my life and improved my
quality of life and there are also dog
friendly, we work locations all
over the place. How Fun is that?
We work caters to everyone
from entrepreneurs and
freelancers to start ups and
even large enterprises including Ge,
salesforce, Microsoft, mastercard,
Samsung, Spotify, Pinterest and red
bull among many others. In fact,
more than 10% of fortune
500 companies currently use.
We work and it's a rapidly growing group.
In other words,
it's not just solar printers and to
ground level startups that use we work,
but everything from that to
the big companies who are
seeing very huge benefits
as well.
We work believes that creating spaces
where people can connect and create
meaning together, right? After all, if
you are someone who has built a business,
modeled on the principles and the
four hour workweek where elsewhere,
it can be a lonely road. Sometimes
even though you're digitally connected,
it can feel very,
very isolating.
So in these spaces you can
connect with real humans and uh,
all the while you space more
efficiently and cost effectively,
which makes you and your business better
equipped to face the challenges of
today and tomorrow.
We work now has more than 200 locations,
so you can find great
spots all over the world.
So head over to we.co/tim that's we dot
Cosio so we.co/tim to become a part of
the global we were community.
At the very least.
I encourage you to check out pictures of
some of the locations around the world.
There are some incredible spots.
So check it.
[inaudible] dot co slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by Peloton
and I'd heard about Peloton over and
over again,
but I ended up getting a Peloton bike
in the whole system after I saw my buddy
Kevin Rose, I've known him
forever, some of you know,
and he showed up at my gate at my house
a while back and he looked fantastic.
I asked him, I said, dude, you look
great. What the hell have you been up to?
Because he's always doing
a weird diet or another,
but it only lasts like a week or two.
So he always regresses to the mean
after like 75 beers and he said,
I've been doing peloton five days a week.
Now.
That caught my attention because Kevin
does nothing five days a week and you
know, I love you Kevin, but
it really peaked my curiosity.
Ended up getting a system and it's
become an integral part of my week.
I love it and I really didn't expect to
love it at all because I find cycling
really boring usually.
But peloton is an indoor cycling bike
that brings live studio classes right into
your home.
You know,
if worry about fitting classes into your
schedule or making it to a studio with
some type of commute,
etc. New classes are added every day and
this includes options led by elite New
York City instructors
in your own living room.
You can even live stream studio classes
taught by the world's best instructors
or find your own favorite class on demand.
And in fact,
Kevin and I rarely do live classes
and you can compete with your friends,
which is also fun.
Kevin,
I'm coming after you but we
usually just use classes on demand.
I really like Matt Wilbur's and his eye
in high intensity training sessions that
are shorter like 20 minutes and I think
Kevin's favorite is Alex and everyone
seems to have their favorite instructor
or you can select by music duration and
so on.
Each Peloton bike includes a 22 inch HD
touchscreen performance tracking metrics.
I think that along with the realtime
leaderboard are the main reasons that this
caught my attention when cycling
never had caught my attention before.
It's really pretty stunning what they've
done with the user interface to keep
your attention.
The belt drive is quiet and it's smaller
than you would expect so it can fit in
a living room or an office.
I actually have it in a large closet,
believe it or not and
it fits with no problem.
So peloton is offering all of you guys,
listeners of the Tim Ferriss show,
a special offer and it is actually
special visit one Peloton that's o,
n e p e l o t o n one peloton.com and
enter the code Tim all caps Tim at
checkout to receive $100 off accessories
with your Peloton bike purchase.
Now you might say ma accessories.
Wait,
I don't need fancy towels or whatever
other supplemental bits and pieces.
No,
the shoes you need,
you need the clip in shoes and
those are in the accessory category.
So there's $100 off is
a very legit $100 off.
So if you want to get in your workouts,
if you want a convenient and really
entertaining way to do high intensity
interval training or anything else or
are you just want to get a fantastic gift
for someone,
check out Peloton one peloton.com
and enter the code Tim again,
that's o n e p e l o t o n.com and enter
the code Tim at checkout to receive
$100 off any accessories including
the shoes that you will want to get.
Check it out,
one peloton.com code Tim.
Okay.
Hello boys and girls.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is typically my job to deconstruct
world class performers of different types
and tease out the habits,
routines, favorite books,
and so on so that you can
apply them to your own life.
This episode is going to
be a little bit different.
So if you want the long form interviews,
go back a few episodes or go to tim.blog
forts as Jamie for Jimmy Fox or Jocko
Willink,
tim.blog/jocko or whatever
might tickle your fancy.
This episode is going to be in
response to many, many, many,
many requests related to my first book,
the four hour Workweek,
which recently celebrated
its 10th anniversary and
thousands of you have asked
me how I would update the four hour
workweek today and you've also asked why I
have not already updated
the four hour work week,
which I did do in fact two years after
2007 and 2009 but why haven't I since and
to answer those questions and many more.
I sat down for an interview where
Ashley asked one of my friends, Adam,
to interview me to
discuss common questions,
misperceptions as well as how I would
walk someone through the book today,
what I might expand if I were to at
the age of 40 as opposed to 29 expand
certain chapters and so on.
So if that's of interest,
then I think this episode we'll have
something for you and if not the long form
interviews, we'll return the
very next episode. And as always,
thank you so much for listening.
I am not Tim Ferriss, but I am
asking questions to Tim Ferris. It's,
it's very meta.
All right Tim,
more than 10 years ago,
four hour work week comes out.
It's published 10 years later.
It is still the most
quoted book on Amazon.
Why has the book had such longevity?
This is a curious question.
The,
the answer is in brief. I'm not sure, uh,
but I would say that if I had to
speculate and come up with something,
I would say I wrote the
very personally to two of my friends
and the backstory on that is when I was
writing the book and there there are many
plausible other explanations and that
the four hour workweek is a title
gets a lot of people to buy the book.
And due to the volume of sales,
there's a high potential for highlighting
since it is a nonfiction how to book
right. Whereas people are less
inclined to highlight a fiction book,
even if it is a thousand times more
popular than the four hour work week.
There are many plausible explanations,
but if I had to take a stab at how
the content or the writing style might
contribute, I would say that when
I started writing the book and uh,
it was largely written in Argentina,
went back to Winos IRA is where
I lived for nine months in 2004,
2005 to right.
And the first attempt failed completely.
I had four or five chapters
that were very academic.
I was trying very hard to sound smart
and not say I never do that now,
but it was really awful to read just
three syllable words where one sober words
would suffice and it was awful.
Uh,
which I think I actually
developed in college.
I think that in the process of writing
papers there, I developed that habit.
So I threw out those four chapters,
four or five chapters.
Then I went the opposite direction and
tried to make it slapstick funny and
really fast and loose and it was equally
bad just for different reasons and
impart both of those failed because
I was writing for a broad audience.
I was trying to write for as many
people as possible and I couldn't do it.
Certainly couldn't do it well,
maybe other people can.
So I sat down and actually opened up a
window to compose an email and started as
a first draft, at least writing
a chapter two, two of my friends,
one who was trapped in a
company of his own making
and felt like he couldn't leave.
He couldn't kill his baby,
it wouldn't run without him,
et Cetera,
which was the exact
situation I had been in.
And another friend who is working at a
bank and was becoming a victim of his own
success.
You had no time and was
deciding to increases burn
rate by things he didn't need
to justify how much time you spent
working felt similarly trapped.
And these were guys
around my age at the time,
29 or so of 29 30 and I knew them really
well because I was effectively them.
I mean we had so much shared experience,
so much your DNA, so many shared goals,
aspirations, problems. And
so I've, I wrote a very,
very personal book ultimately
with two friends in mind.
And I think that the
feedback I very often get,
I don't think I know feedback very often
get with the book is I felt like you
were writing it just to me.
Okay.
And I had a very,
very narrow focus to begin with.
Meaning I'm writing for effectively
people who have very similar life
circumstances or goals,
aspirations, fears, trappings.
And it was
by definition,
if you look at who's writing the book
going to be males in a fairly narrow age
range who are tech savvy,
very interested in a handful of things.
But it's important to realize that the,
the target isn't the market.
And this is not something I made up.
I don't know who originally
to attribute it to,
but my original target just so I could
write effectively from my own experience
was that group.
But as soon as it came out,
then it immediately bled over into women
who fit the same psychographics and so
on. And then it started to bleed
out by age. And now if I go,
I've been to commencement speeches where
the the parents or grandparents will
come over and ask me about the four hour
work week because they read it and then
I have high school students
who are reading it.
So the original market was very,
very,
very narrow.
That does not mean in some cases,
certainly in the case of this book
that it can't expand later. Uh,
that's my best guess.
That's my best guess is that it's very
personally written and it's also in the
category of advice how to nonfiction,
which is prone to receiving more
highlights. Right. To begin with.
So I know you've been asked many times,
and I've thought about it as well about
updating the book because a lot has
changed in,
in more than 10 years.
But I also know as as everyone else
that you have held back on that urge.
Why is it that you have decided at least
so far to not make any changes to the
book and updated?
Yeah, this is a good question. There are,
this is something that I have had a
tremendous amount of internal debate about
and internal conflict about.
On one hand,
I really want to provide the latest
and greatest and cutting edge to my
audience. On the other hand, in the
format of a book that is a losing battle.
It is a fool's errand because as soon
as I update the tech and the tools,
it will be outdated six months later.
It would need to be completely rewritten,
uh, in most cases. So if we
look at the four hour work week,
I would say there are few levels to the
framework and strategies and advice.
In the book,
you have principles to
the first principles,
like ordering principles
that are the most important.
If you understand those principles, you
can usually come up with SEI strategies,
which are broad approaches to solving
certain problems, maybe even frameworks.
So we could call also the principles,
core beliefs or assumptions.
Let's just say then you have it
or if then statements, right?
Then you have the strategies which are,
we'll given those assumptions
and first principles.
Here are the broad strategies which do
not include tools or specific tactics.
Then you go up a level and you have
tools and tactics. For instance,
using Google adwords to test,
which was very effective and one
of the primary options at the time,
the four hour workweek was
published that would now be at,
at the very least supplemented with safe
Facebook advertising and other types of
contextual advertising and
testing and so on and so forth.
There are many,
many more platform options and testing
options than existed when the book was
first published in 2007 meaning the
book was written in 2005 2006 right?
It was updated in 2009 so
it's moderately updated,
but the the tools and tactics
are always going to change.
And for that reason,
I encourage people,
and the reason I haven't updated those
in the written format in the book thus
far is that if you understand the
focus on the principles and strategies,
you can figure out the tools and tactics.
And in fact you're going to have to do
that if you're going to choose to be an
entrepreneur or someone to
make something from nothing.
Let's just say very broadly speaking or
someone who moves assets and resources
from an area of low economic yield
to an area of high economic yield,
which was the, one of the
original definitions from JB say,
I believe his name was,
you are going to have to become very
good at improvising and problem solving.
So if you're not willing to figure
out the tools and tactics on your own,
I would say you were ill equipped at,
or unwilling to be what it is required
to achieve any mode come of success as an
entrepreneur. Right?
And that's not just me.
Absolving myself with the responsibility
of updating the principles and the
strategies are very
important. 80 20 analysis. Uh,
let's just say some assumptions
which could be falsified,
but that time is the most
valuable nonrenewable resource
compared to say income,
right? All of these then
inform the later decisions.
So book is not the best format for
tracking technology. Nonetheless,
it would be nice to update but it
would be better done via some type of
community online or online repository.
I tried that with a forum and it
turned into, as you're well aware,
a gigantic pain in the ass
headache. So I euthanized that. Uh,
the other piece of it is part two.
So if part one is tools and tactics change
too quickly and I would have to put a
lot of effort into updating,
that would immediately be obsolescence.
The second piece of it is looking back,
say at the four hour workweek.
There are parts of it that
make me cringe a little bit.
Not that I regret having
written it the way I wrote it,
but the 29 year old Tim Ferriss felt like
he had a lot to prove and he did have
a lot to prove.
I mean there are the hundreds of
thousands of books published every year.
And I had at that time,
no media training.
I was utterly unprepared for everything
that transpired because the initial
print, well the book was first
of all turned down by 27,
I think it's 27 publishers,
just a few violently in some cases.
And then the initial print run
was between 10 and 12,000 copies.
You couldn't even get it in
many places in the u s alone.
The book was not expected to do much
at all and therefore I was completely
unprepared for everything that
came afterward in writing the book.
Also in writing for my two friends,
uh,
I was very much myself at the
time and myself at the time,
had a bit of chest puffing,
a very hyper aggressive,
uh,
and looking back,
if I were to edit the book now,
it would have a very different voice.
It would have a very different tone,
have a very different feel. But
the four hour work week now has been
translated into more than 40 languages.
It is almost always in the top 100
top 200 on Amazon. Like you said,
for 2017 it was the most highlighted
book across all of Amazon,
which was even to me a big surprise.
And there's a certain,
for lack of a better word,
there's certain magic or alchemy in that
book that made it click and still makes
it click 10 years later that
I don't want to fuck with.
I'm really afraid that if I go
in there and start tinkering,
that I'm going to step on the
butterfly that then, you know,
causes like I a hurricane on the other
side of the world within the book,
that that somehow affects
what that book is done.
And
if it's not broken,
I don't want to try to fix it.
So that's another reason why if we look
at not just the tools and resources and
so on,
if I were to go into the book,
I worry that I would tinker
in a way that would damage it.
And if people want to read
the later, Tim, they can.
It's very easy. You just
read the later books, right?
Each of those books is a snapshot of me
at a very particular point in my life
and although I wouldn't view
them as autobiographical,
they absolutely capture a lot of my goals,
priorities,
neuroses,
and so on of a given point in my life.
Uh, so those are a few of the reasons
why I have chosen not to update the book.
If there was a section or two which
you've been asked a thousand or two times
two update,
is there anything that comes to mind
that now feels a little outdated and son
that when you think of today what
you were doing, you would be like,
you know what,
here's how I would refresh that section.
There are
a few sections.
I say broadly speaking, since the four
hour work weeks broken into definition,
elimination, automation,
liberation, the automation section,
which talks about business
process outsourcing delegation,
the tools that can be used for that,
uh,
certainly the testing components of
what we might call now developing,
launching, iterating on a minimally,
a minimum viable product, MVP.
Those could all be updated and I left
out another reason why updating is
challenging and I would
take it one step further.
We're talking about tools and tactics,
right? Right. We come down a level,
let's consider the principles and
strategies. Let's take art as an example.
Drawing.
All right,
so you might have certain principles and
organizing principles which are beliefs
about materials and two d and so on
for charcoal or some type of drawing.
Then you have strategies or
just composition and so on.
Then you have the tools given
pens, pencils, and so on.
Given my audience right now,
if I recommend a given pen,
right,
it is almost certainly
immediately going to be sold out.
That problem which has been nicknamed
the hug of death by some of my fans
applies even more so to services.
So if I recommend a given service that
currently has a few thousand users or
even tens of thousands and then they
get hit by a million or 2 million,
it can absolutely destroy the service,
particularly if it's not automated and
there's some type of client interaction
or customer service. If there is a manual
component, I can completely destroy it.
So I am,
I am loath to in some cases
recommend any particular,
I get asked all the time, all right,
which outsourcing service should I use?
I would like to get a virtual
assistant in the Philippines or India.
Who should I use?
Well,
I've made those recommendations in the
past and within a week they go from five
out of five star in customer service
to one out of five star. Right? Why?
Because they suddenly have to 10 x their
client capacity overnight and very few
service businesses are equipped
to handle that. Almost none.
But if I had a gun to the
head and had to update, uh,
particularly with tools
that can handle and scale,
maybe they're based on AWS or otherwise,
right?
Amazon web services are
not as prone to crashing.
And being destroyed.
Then it would be the the muse development
testing components for those people
who don't know the term use,
referring to a cash flow
optimized business that can
scale effectively without
scaling and headcount,
uh, or hours necessarily.
And the other elements of
delegation and automation,
those,
those I think from a tactic standpoint
are the most outdated and therefore what
I'm asked most frequently for,
right.
So if people were to listen to the
podcast and read the book or read the book
and then listen to the podcast as one
would hope after 10 years there's been,
as you've been talking about a
shift in mindset and personality.
If you were to rewrite it, would there
be a section that you would add to that?
Obviously so much about
mindset and mental approach,
stoicism sign that has
come into your life.
Would there be an element that you would
add that maybe 29 year old Tim 20 year
old Tim never even realize the importance
that it played in terms of either
growing a business or having a mindset
that would allow you to not only sustain,
say success,
but happiness with that success.
I would expand a section that
I think gets overlooked a lot.
There is a section or a chapter called
filling the void and it's a really,
really, really important chapter that
most people don't pay much attention to.
And it answers the question,
what should I do once I have created a
self sustaining semi or fully automated
business that funds all of my cashflow
requirements and I have location
independence and flexibility with time,
uh,
w hence the chapter title,
which is filling the void,
how to reallocate your time and
direct your focus once you've
gained a few rungs on Maslow's
hierarchy of needs. Right? So you're,
you're paying your rent, you're covering
all your, uh, all of your material needs.
Then what,
and this relates to a common
misconception of the four hour work week,
which is,
oh,
the objective is to just sit on
a beach sipping a Pina Colada,
rubbing cocoa butter on your stomach for
the rest of your life. Wait, wait, wait.
That wasn't the point. Or
somehow being idle, right? The,
the objective is to whatever,
just live spring break,
24 seven for the rest of your life.
And the people who lodge that
complaint a haven't read the book,
but they,
they,
they very specifically have missed
this filling the void chapter,
which talks about contribution
getting outside of a me,
me,
me focus.
So that you are hopefully putting a
positive dent in the world in a way that
certainly extends outside of yourself
and even your immediate family,
but also hopefully has some type of
persistence over time so that you leave a
hesitate to use the word because
it's so loaded and has some baggage,
but a legacy of some type a.
And so that really you're taking the
tools you've developed in a business
capacity and applying them
to impact in some fashion,
whether that's focused on education,
scientific research,
where I'm spending a lot of time actually
focused on both of those and have been
for a very long time. Uh, I,
I think I would expand that and make it
clear that that is mandatory reading.
It's not a nice to have when
you have an extra few hours,
five years from now, you should
read this. It's like, no,
I expect that many
people skipped it because
maybe they don't expect to succeed.
Right, right. They're like, Hey,
I'll cross that bridge when I get to it.
I don't have to even think about it now.
And the fact of the matter is, you
know, thousands, tens of thousands,
hundreds of thousands of
people have created these
businesses and then they fuck
up that part. Right. And they
get, even in some cases they get,
and this is really common there.
Location Independent.
A lot of their friends
have nine to five jobs.
And what started off as a party
and a celebration. Oh my God,
I can't believe I figured it out.
Ends up being very,
very lonely and they feel really isolated
and they don't know how to address
that.
And the way you dress that is by
digging your wells before you're dry and
thinking about that,
filling the void and starting
to incorporate those pieces
into your life before
you end up in a maybe a, a,
a challenging emotional psychological
position where you're on your heels a bit,
you end up being reactive or uh,
so set in your ways.
Even if you are,
even if you are technically
financially independent,
since you haven't filled the void
with anything non business related,
you were just going to continue to work
for work sick. This is really common.
This is the default, right? For
people who succeed in any capacity,
to the extent that they no longer need
additional income or cashflow OER or
liquid net worth, it's,
it's really common.
It's very rare that you find someone
who's been in sixth gear for a very long
time who then retires and is really
good at chilling the fuck out, right?
Not Common learning to relax and enjoy.
Other aspects of life and
engage with people around you,
friends and community or build community.
Those are skills that you
have to practice and develop.
Just like you need to
develop and practice the,
of split testing for
headlines or anything else.
It's not a default ability that you have
as soon as you hit stop and so called
retire or do something like that. Uh, so
I, I would spend a bit more time on that.
I think that is the chapter that I'm,
I was qualified right at the time,
but I'm much more qualified to right now
because I've had so much more practice
I've just had put on a lot more mileage
and done a lot more experimentation and
have had the ability to observe dozens
and hundreds at this point of mega
successful people who have
grappled with some of these,
these issues that can be
really existential for someone.
If the business has been your identity
for a long time and all of a sudden you
want to replace that. If you don't
have a compelling replacement,
you will just continue working because
you don't want to sacrifice that identity.
And how, how can someone possibly
prepare for that? Because I think what,
and you can correct me if I'm wrong,
is probably been amazing for you to see
is the number of businesses and success
stories that have born out
of four hour work week.
You obviously expected that when you
wrote it, it would be able to help people.
But over 10 years,
the number of huge businesses that
have been started out of thin air,
it's not even like you were accelerating.
People quit their job,
started this and it had
it built out of nowhere.
How do you take someone who's just like,
maybe maybe this could work and then
they do it and the next thing they know
they do it because they want to believe,
but they probably don't believe in
the first place. But as you said,
if you don't have that preparation,
you might wake up one day and find
yourself in a position that you're,
you're not prepared for. So when, when
someone comes into this with the mindset,
I want to give this a try.
It's like when people want to lose weight,
everyone wants to lose weight.
Everyone wants to make more money,
but very few people actually
believe and then they,
they follow the steps and they get there
and they're like, oh, what now? Yeah.
How do you build a mindset that is
prepared for reality that a part of you
probably doesn't even think is real?
I would say in the beginning,
aside from making sure you're exercising
and taking care of the highest value
asset you have,
uh,
you're going to need to
throw a lot against the wall
with the business to figure
out what works. You can't
do an 80, 20 analysis if you
don't have anything to add,
to analyze, right? So you're going to
have to try many, many, many, many,
many things to figure out what you're
good at, what you're enthusiastic about.
And uh, to succeed and endure
are respectively, you need both.
You have to have endurance and
you have to have ability and,
and that can be God given talent or
it can be skill that you developed.
But in all of those cases,
you need to throw a lot against the wall.
So in the beginning there isn't going
to be much diversification of identity.
You're going to have to really
throw a lot against the wall.
That's the front loading period.
Then you can start to do 80,
20 analysis and so on.
I would say once the business has enough
traction that you've proven what the
tech world would call product market fit
and you believe you might have a tiger
by the tail that you can
grow in a meaningful way.
Once you have that,
there are a few steps you can take.
Number one is to
okay
build a business that you can sell
even if you never plan on selling it.
This is a very helpful,
not just thought exercise but blueprint
to keep in mind and lens through which
you should look at your business.
And there are, there are other books out
there that I think can be quite helpful.
Uh,
the e myth revisited is one
looks mostly it's service businesses
but could be applied to product built to
sell by John Warrillow is a book that
I found very interesting to ponder and
when you start to
look at your business as something as
another product that you are going to
ultimately sell,
you remove single points of failure,
key man or key women risk.
You begin to really emphasize process
instead of just results which you can get.
I mean if you're a type a super driven
person with some ability and some
numeracy so you can analyze things,
well you can white knuckle your
way to a fair amount of money,
but you might be rewarding really
unsustainable bad process because you're
getting good results and not
only does that not scale,
it's unsustainable.
You will burn out or most people will
certainly or you'll be miserable and you
most certainly can't sell it unless
you want to be attached to it forever.
And
I would view that as lens slash.
Step number one is once you have some
traction and you believe that you can pour
gasoline on something that
is already working, okay,
now let's take step back.
Look at your org chart.
You don't need a lot of headcount.
It's could still be a one person business,
but how can I automate certain things?
How can I empower,
say freelancers or a fulfillment centers,
companies I work with to make autonomous
decisions and otherwise create recipes
and policies that replace me as a
bottleneck that needs to make one off
decisions over and over and over again.
That's really important.
The second would be simultaneously
or shortly thereafter,
diversifying your identity. You asked
about happy and it's a bit earlier,
let's just call it sense of wellbeing,
sense of inner peace,
just feeling unconflicted,
uh, and unanxious.
Perhaps.
What I found very effective for
that is diversifying your identity.
What does that mean?
If the thing you do,
and having lived in silicon
valley for 17 years, you know,
recently moved to Austin, but having
lived in silicon valley for so long,
you see people who in some cases
by necessity, unfortunately in, uh,
in sometimes a zero sum game of
venture back startups, they're only,
they're only identity is their startup.
And if the startup has a good day,
they have a good day and they
feel good about themselves.
If their startup has a bad day,
they have a bad,
they have a bad day and they
feel badly about themselves.
And there are factors outside of
your control when you run a business.
Clearly there are many factors within
your control, but there are many,
many factors outside of your control,
macroeconomic climate, stock market,
the amount of disposable income
that your customers may have. A,
if you're heavily weighted with,
say,
a handful of distributors or clients
and they represent a large percentage of
your sales or income,
also a palpable risk factor,
right? And who knows?
Like I, for instance,
I had an experience when I was running
one of my first businesses and, uh,
the,
uh,
one of my primary customers
had a key man risk. I,
he a president who made a lot of
decisions. Yeah, he had a heart attack.
You need an emergency surgery.
And the second command who was effectively
the default succession plans that hey,
we need to like,
we need to stop a bunch of what we're
doing just to get back on our feet.
Just totally understandable,
but it put my business
into a very reactive,
a precarious position. Right. All right,
so thinking through all these, but we're,
we're,
I'm going with that is if you are building
a muse or business is based on the
principles and strategies and so on, in
the four hour workweek, in some capacity,
you, I would encourage you to diversify
your identity, which means having,
say a,
a consistent physical
practice that is goal based.
So when I was writing the four hour
body, I had a dead lifting protocol, uh,
among other things based on what sprint
coach Barry Ross and awful Po Pavel
Tsatsouline,
which what they had taught me related
to developing maximal and relative
strength and the deadlift. And if I
had a really tough week with my book,
so authors do this too. They go into
this cave, which is book deadline.
And if they make progress on a book
in a week, they have a good week,
they feel good.
If they do not make progress,
they hit a roadblock or are
simply having difficulty writing.
It can, it can throw them existentially
into a really dark place. But all right.
Had a terrible day writing, but put
10 pounds on my dead lift. Good day.
All right.
So you have now multiple silos in which
independent silos within which you can
win.
And so you could have,
let's just say startup or book,
then you have something exercise-based
could be rock climbing, could be religion,
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu, Acroyoga. It
doesn't matter. Something consistent,
ideally with other people.
All right?
Not In your garage gym. Uh,
which I had at the time,
but I chose to go to a rock climbing
gym where they also had weight training
facilities to be around other people.
This is undervalued.
And then the next piece could be
anything. It could be voice lessons,
could be a musical instrument,
could be some type of artwork.
It doesn't matter. But these are
three independent silos or more.
I usually have two or three
so that if one of these fails,
it's self contained,
right?
Sort of like on any type of cruise ship
or a large seaborne vessel at this point
you will have compartments so that
if something terrible happens,
it gets punctured by an iceberg,
something like that.
The whole ship doesn't go down. It
is a self contained, controllable,
uh, set of damage. Right?
I think that you can view your identity
very similarly and you want to set that
up before you need it.
Do not wait until one of,
do not wait until your single silo fails
to then try to build the other two.
You have to preemptively put it in place.
Right?
So those are a few of the things that,
that I think about and have implemented
quite a bit for myself and that I've
seen successfully
implemented by other people.
I would call you overall insatiable when
it comes to the things that you want to
do and the goals that you want to achieve
and the speed and level of achievement
that you want to achieve them in.
I imagine it was the same way
when you're writing this book,
but I also know that you
are much more reflective.
What would Tim Ferriss right now tell
the Tim Ferriss who is writing for our
work week? Knowing right now
the success the book has had,
how many people it is genuinely helped
and the, and the difference it's made, uh,
you know,
overall to so many people's lives.
I think there's going to be a very
dissatisfying answer that always works up.
I don't think I tell him anything until
the book was done because, and this is,
this is a dissatisfying answer that a
lot of my interviewees on the podcast get
me and I'm always like, ah,
come on. But they're like, hey,
much like me with my hesitancy to go
back and edit the four hour work week.
It's like, I don't want to step
on that one butterfly. That then
changes everything,
the entire trajectory.
And if you think about it in a given day,
I remember I was,
I was contemplating this at one point.
We think of life changing as big events.
X,
Y and Z was life changing. X, Y and
Z changed my life. Some big event,
but almost decision,
every act you take it every given
moment in a day is by definition life
changing.
He choose to breathe in a certain way
or hold your breath or drink coffee
instead of water. These are
all life changing events. Uh,
if you were to look at two
parallel movies of your life,
choosing to take an Uber versus walking,
I mean, these can all change your life.
So I,
I don't
underestimate the impact
of seemingly small changes.
I wouldn't say anything to him until
he had finished the book. Even then,
I might say nothing.
But if I were to tell him anything
at maybe a few critical junctures,
I'd say everything's going to be okay.
You can probably get what you need done,
but dial back the anxiety and worry at
least 20% I don't think Tim of 29 would
have listened. I would
agree. But nonetheless,
maybe I would say something like that.
Uh,
what I would probably say
to Tim at multiple points
is something that came up in
tribe of mentors. My last
book repeatedly, which was
there've been multiple points where
I have felt like a failure or have
experienced what from every vantage
point objectively looks like a business
failure or publishing failure or
a huge mistake, gigantic fuck up.
And something that came up a lot in
interviews for the last book was sometimes
you need life to save you from what
you want so you can get what you need.
And this is another reason
why I now ask so many people,
what is your favorite failure?
Meaning a failure that in retrospect set
you up for a much larger success later.
And I've really,
yeah.
Suffered.
Okay.
From overly fixating on and worrying
about what seem like or seemed like
failures as caused me
a lot of pain and uh,
both in the present moment and looking
back at it and wondering about the
persistent effects of that
so called failure. Um, so
I, I think I would say, Hey,
I know this seems like a
catastrophe at the moment,
but this is actually going to
okay,
open a door that you can't even imagine
right now to greater opportunities.
And that might sound like some bullshit,
shallow motivational speaker nonsense.
Like in fact like, trust me,
I can't tell you what it is,
but just like this is going to serve you.
And that's true.
I mean if you look back at for instance,
the very difficult experience which
was publishing the four hour chef,
and I won't go into
great detail about this,
but does it incredibly difficult to write,
very proud of it, but almost killed me.
I mean physically it was one of the most
difficult books to write, put together.
Very complex,
lots of moving pieces.
It was because it was published by Amazon
and was the first major acquisition by
what was then announced to be Amazon
publishing. It was boycotted by everybody,
Barnes and noble indies,
big box retailers.
People wouldn't carry it. And uh, it was,
it was an extremely, extremely painful,
let's just say two to three years for me.
And I was burned out. I was
completely burned out. So I was,
I was really just depressed
and demoralized and felt
like hiding from the world
during.
And after that experience,
I was so burned out that I decided to
take a break from writing and I decided to
do something lighter because during
the promotion of the four hour chef,
even though the book didn't
perform the way I had wanted it to,
I had this experience with
the new format called podcast.
And I was interviewed by Mark Marin
and Joe Rogan and the Nerdist gang,
including Chris Hardwick and I,
I had so much fun during this podcast
and I could be myself and we could get
into the weeds because it wasn't
two to three minutes on television.
I wondered to myself,
what if I tried that?
And just like those guys
edit very minimally and use
it as an opportunity to get
better at asking questions to get rid
of some of my verbal ticks and use it as
an excuse to talk to more interesting
people and record it and be more social
because I'm prone to isolating myself.
Why not?
Why don't I give that a shot
and try it for six episodes?
So if I hadn't had what I considered
a complete catastrophe at the time,
this podcast wouldn't even exist,
which has turned into something much,
arguably a much bigger than
all of my books combined,
at least based on feedback from listeners
and certainly based on monthly reach.
That's one of many, many examples.
So I think I would say, look,
just trust me because I'm your future
use so I know more than you do actually
kid. Uh, this seems like a mess,
but you need life to save you from what
you want sometimes to give you what you
really need.
And Trust me,
this apparent failure is going
to give you like a hundred x.
On the flip side,
just be fucking patient and don't do
anything stupid and self destructive cause
you're really depressed and sad right now.
That's what I would say.
And how important is that that the failure
can really happen at any point? Yeah,
I mean when you think
about four hour chef,
you had two number one bestsellers
at that point and four work week.
I think it was on the bestseller list for
forever is a good way to put it. Yeah,
like foreign almost five years straight.
Yeah.
It's so knowing that a lot of people
associate failure at the beginning when
they start with the failure can happen
at any point and that resilience is
important.
How much has that,
almost even the lesson that needs
to be applied to four workweek,
if someone is picking it up or going
back or thinking about giving some of the
recommendations to try. Um, I
think resiliency as you said,
it's something that you've learned but
as it's something that you can prepare
for as you tried to start something new,
which is scary for anyone.
There are many ways to practice
it in many ways to train yourself.
I won't beat a dead horse on
stoicism since I've certainly
talked a lot about it,
but still philosophy, Seneca
Marcus realized have both
been very, very helpful.
And for those people who have no
familiarity, I'm not going to get into it.
But you can,
you can Google Tao of Seneca.
I've put together gigantic compilation
that contained some of my favorite
writing.
It's available for free as an ebook.
You can find it easily Tao Tao of Seneca,
but you know, everyone from
Bill Bellacheck, right?
Competitor supreme in the, uh, in
certainly in the football arena.
I to George Washington,
Thomas Jefferson. I mean,
you go through prisoners of
war from Vietnam War and,
and other periods have all cited
it or in some fashion. Actually,
Bill Belicheck hasn't personally cited,
but I know that the Patriots Seahawks
and so on at every possible level, uh,
have consumed stoicism as a
means of competitive advantage.
But in terms of developing resilience
and tempering emotional reactivity so you
can make better decisions, that's a
fantastic tool. It's really a tool kit.
So that's one. Uh, in general
I would say on a daily basis.
And this is especially true for
me in the last six months, uh,
actually with the help of Tony Robbins.
So I've gotten to know over the last few
years and Tony's one of those people who
it's easy to be skeptical of
Tony. Uh, I've always been a fan.
I mean my very first business was a
byproduct in part of listening to personal
power too,
which I bought used at a used bookstore
and listened to in my crappy hand me
down piece of Shit Green
Minivan, which my, uh,
my coworkers affectionately nicknamed
the molester mobile. Thanks guys.
I'm not because I'm a molester,
but because it was a fucking beat up
minivan that looked like something out of
silence of the lambs and uh, got,
had the seats stolen out of the back,
which didn't help matters
the long story anyway.
I would get stuck in traffic
on one oh one in the bay area,
which anyone who's done it knows sucks
and listened to Tony robins back and
forth. And then, so it's very largely
responsible for my first business.
In any case, I've gotten to know
Tony over the last few years.
I've attended two of his events, have
spent a lot of time with him in person,
had him on the podcast a
couple of times and he's,
he's more impressive the
better you get to know him.
And what would he really drove home
for me in the last few months is the
importance of trying to identify your
primary question or primary questions that
you ask yourself as a means
of dictating behavior.
And it's very often something
subconscious. So it could be,
and this is very common for folks,
you know,
am I good enough or why am I not good
enough or what the fuck's wrong with me?
Like these are very common
default questions that
unsurprisingly then results in
many types of debilitating
thought patterns, neuroses,
sabotaging behaviors in relationships,
whatever it might be,
and spending time and Tony's the right
guy to look to for direction on that.
I'm not going to do it justice here,
but figuring out your default questions
and then crafting new to fall questions.
So my default question or
one of my default questions
now that I try to revisit
on a daily basis, because again,
you have to practice this stuff.
It's not like you just decide,
write it on a piece of paper and then
your life is changed forever and your
behaviors upgraded and definitely no,
you have to practice this stuff is,
you know, how can I even more
so appreciate this as a gift,
right? And there's, there's,
there's, there's a bit more
nuance to it, but let's,
let's take a simple version.
How can,
I appreciate this as a gift
and specifically that is
to be used when you are
frustrated,
when someone is challenging you,
when you get an email or a phone call
you hate, that throws you into a tizzy.
When things happen that you would normally
look at as a problem or perhaps at
best a challenge. Like how can
you view this as a gift? Oh,
you're stuck in traffic. You're
going to miss your flight. Okay,
this is a chance to practice
cause guess what? You're missing.
You're fucking flight no matter what.
So how can you view this as a gift?
Like what is this an opportunity to do?
Uh,
that is another way to develop an ability
to reframe quickly that is incredibly
pragmatic and incredibly effective for
becoming less reactive and more able to
be responsible in the
sense of response able,
you're choosing your response and
that perhaps more than anything else,
if you want some semblance of
wellbeing or feeling of inner peace,
it is that it is not,
by the way,
I mean if you look at a lot of the noise
and craziness right now in the media
cycle,
there are many people who are training
themselves and encouraging other people
to try to make everyone in the,
in the world change their behavior to
make everyone other than themselves less
offensive, right? This is the
opposite of making yourself resilient.
It is much more,
much more practical and possible to train
yourself to be less easily offended,
to train yourself to reframe
so that you can take people,
many of which are never going to change
the behaviors and repurpose what they
might present you with as
an opportunity or a gift.
This doesn't mean you don't
call out terrible behavior.
It doesn't mean that at some points
you don't put on brass knuckles,
metaphorically speaking and like
deck someone in the face. Yeah,
there are times when you fight,
but if your default is always fighting,
not a good approach,
you're not going to have the stamina
or the strength to actually fight the
larger necessary fights and uh,
you're going to exhaust yourself and
you're going to alienate people. Uh,
I remember a very good friend,
actually, I won't mention him by name,
but mutual friend of ours said to me
at one point who, who works with very,
very high level players
in many different worlds.
He's a bit of a consigliere area and he
said to be over dinner once. He said,
cause I was,
I was laying out all of these various
initiatives and causes and so on.
I wanted to pursue in the new year.
This was a few years ago and he said,
I think you should as a thought exercise,
just imagine that you have six bullets.
You have a revolver,
a six bullets,
and that's all you get to spend
over the next year or two.
You have six things you can take
really seriously and do very publicly.
That's it.
So pick those very wisely,
which is not unlike Warren Buffett's
approach to saying, here's your,
here's your card.
You have 10 hole punches.
Those are the investments you get to
make for the rest of your life just as a
means of pumping the brakes and making
better decisions. I think that's a useful,
a useful way to think of things. So those
are a few, few things that come to mind.
I will not make you a do a request of
your audience or ask you what will go on
your billboard,
but I will ask you that if someone were
to go back and reread the four hour work
week or if they were to pick it up
for the first time. As you mentioned,
tons of people are still
discovering this book, which is a,
I think part of the beauty of it.
What would you tell them to keep in mind
as they're reading through it to really
make it or allow it to have
the greatest impact on them?
Uh,
I would say a few things.
Number one is that if the, the, the brash,
uh, aggressive Tim Ferriss and it the shit
out of you at points, you're not alone.
And try not to throw the
baby out with the bathwater.
Meaning I am conveying in that
book principles, strategies,
approaches that I have collected
from other places and other experts.
So if for whatever reason
the tone annoys you,
try as an exercise to absorb the message
without getting obsessed with the
messenger, number one.
And for what it's worth,
that's not true for a very percentage
of people. But there's some folks,
for whatever reason, uh, many
valid, I'm sure, uh, find,
find the tone,
particularly in the first baby chapter
two to be a little off putting.
So just go into it,
maybe expecting that and ride it out a
second.
I would say that the,
the tools and practices like the fear
setting chapter and the fear setting,
exercise, 80, 20 analysis, these
are not one and done practices.
These are
practices like having blood work done
every quarter or once a year that you
repeat over time and that become
more and more valuable over time.
The better you get at implementing them
and the better versed and more nuanced
you become and using them.
Uh, that's what I would say.
Uh, those are two. And then last perhaps,
which relates to everything we've been
talking about is focus first and foremost
on the,
the different reframing of
assumptions about life and principles,
the core tenants of the book,
the strategies and don't get overly
distracted by the tools and tactics.
So if you're not interested
in building your own business,
uh, or building a business along the
lines of what is described in the book,
that's fine.
Just focus on the higher level concepts.
And this has been applied by
many, many, many people. I mean,
if you look at some of the most successful
venture capitalists are billionaires
who certainly do not have what they
would consider a four hour workweek. Uh,
nonetheless,
a lot of them have read this book and
been quoted in The New York Times and
other other profiles that,
that, that are out there. Uh,
you have people working in say
education or defense contractors or uh,
even attorneys who have read the book at
V and operate at a very high level who
are applying the
principles in some fashion,
maybe just 10% and seeing a very dramatic
results but not building a business
and don't get fixated on the,
the type of pen that is being used or the
type of Kranz being used. Look at the,
look at the concepts of composition
and then the principles of drawing and
artwork and learn those because they are
transferable to many different areas.
Awesome. Thank you, Tim. All right. Yeah,
my pleasure. Thanks for hanging out.
Hey guys, this is Tim again. Just a
few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy a short email from me
every Friday that provides a little more
soul of fun before the weekend and five
bullet Friday is a very short email where
I share the coolest things I've found
or that I've been pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets
and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the other
world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance,
and it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work
week.com that's four hour work,
week.com all spelled out and just drop
in your email and you will get the very
next one. And if you sign
up, I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by Peloton.
And I'd heard about Peloton
over and over again,
but I ended up getting a Peloton
bike and the whole system,
after I saw my buddy Kevin Rose, I've
known of forever, some of you know,
and he showed up at my gate at my house
a while back and he looked fantastic.
I asked him as a dude, you look great,
what the hell have you been up to?
Because he's always doing
a weird diet or another,
but it only lasts like a week or two.
So he always regresses to the mean
after like 75 beers and he said,
I've been doing Peloton
five days a week now.
That caught my attention because Kevin
does nothing five days a week and you
know, I love you Kevin, but
it really peaked my curiosity.
Ended up getting a system and it's
become an integral part of my week.
I love it and I really didn't expect to
love it at all because I find cycling
really boring usually.
But peloton is an indoor cycling bike
that brings live studio classes right into
your home.
You don't have to worry about fitting
classes into your schedule and making it
to a studio with some type of commute,
etc. New classes are added every day and
this includes options led by elite New
York City instructors
in your own living room.
You can even livestream studio classes
taught by the world's best instructors or
find your own favorite class on demand
and in fact Kevin and I rarely do live
classes and you can compete with your
friends, which is also fun. Kevin,
I'm coming after you but we
usually just use classes on demand.
I really like Matt Wilbur's and his iron,
high intensity training sessions that
are shorter like 20 minutes and I think
Kevin's favorite is Alex and everyone
seems to have their favorite instructor or
you can select by music
duration and so on.
Each Peloton bike includes a 22 inch HD
touchscreen performance tracking metrics.
I think that that along with the real
time leaderboard are the main reasons that
this caught my attention when cycling
never had caught my attention before.
It's really pretty stunning what they've
done with the user interface to keep
your attention. The belt drive is
quiet and it's than you would expect.
So it can fit in a
living room or an office.
I actually have it in a large closet
of belief or not and it fits with no
problem.
So peloton is offering all of you guys,
listeners of the Tim Ferriss show,
a special offer and it is
actually a special visit,
one Peloton that's o n e p e l o t o n
one peloton.com and enter the code Tim
all caps Tim at checkout to receive $100
off accessories with your Peloton bike
purchase. Now you might
say man accessories, wait,
I don't need fancy towels or whatever
other supplemental bits and pieces.
No,
the shoes you need,
you need the clip in shoes and
those are in the accessory category.
So this a hundred dollars off
is a very legit, $100 off.
So if you want to get in your workouts,
if you want a convenient and really
entertaining way to do high intensity
interval training or anything else,
or are you just want to get
a fantastic gift for someone.
Check out Peloton one peloton.com
and enter the code Tim again,
that's o n e p e l o t o n.com and enter
the code Tim at checkout to receive
$100 off any accessories including
the shoes that you will want to get.
Check it out one peloton.com code.
Tim,
this episode is brought to you
by we work. I love, we work.
I haven't had an office
in many, many, many, many,
many years since 2000 or so
when I had my last real job,
I suppose and quotation marks.
But when I moved from San Francisco
to Austin not long ago, I decided,
you know what, I'm tired of
working at home. I'm tired of,
we're going to coffee shops.
So one of the very first things I
did was to get a space at we work.
I could not be happier with this change
of how we work is a global network of
workspaces where companies and people
grow together. The idea is really simple.
You focus on your business and we work
takes care of all the rest including
front desk service until
Idis refreshments and more.
I also often have been shipped from
Amazon and elsewhere to my office that we
work here in Austin.
I've been completely blown away
by the members only events,
special offers and perhaps the best cold
brew coffee on tap that I've ever had.
It's been amazing.
It's been a real,
real change in my life and improved my
quality of life and there are also dog
friendly. We work locations all
over the place. How Fun is that?
We work caters to everyone
from entrepreneurs and
freelancers to startups and
even large enterprises including Ge,
salesforce, Microsoft, mastercard,
Samsung, Spotify, Pinterest and red
bull among many others. In fact,
more than 10% of fortune
500 companies currently use.
We work and it's a rapidly growing group.
In other words,
it's not just solar printers and to
ground level startups that use we work,
but everything from that to the big
companies who are seeing it's a very huge
benefits as well.
We worked believes that create spaces
where people can connect with and create
meaning together.
Right after all,
if you are someone who has
built a business model on
the principles and the four
hour workweek or elsewhere,
it can be a lonely road.
Sometimes even though you're
digitally connected, it can feel very,
very isolating.
So in these spaces you can
connect with real humans and uh,
all the while you space more efficiently
and cost effectively, which makes it,
you end your business better equipped
to face the challenges of today and
tomorrow.
We work now has more than 200 locations
so you can find great spots all over the
world.
So head over to [inaudible] dot co
slash Tim that's [inaudible] dot co CEO
we.co/tim to become a part of
the global New York community.
At the very least,
I encourage you to check out pictures of
some of the locations around the world.
There are some incredible spots, so check
it out. [inaudible] dot co slash Tim.